hi there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
Paula is assembling her headphones this
is Paula hi I'm Paula dimming and these
are my headphones they're not actually
mine Greg's letting me use them that's
how it works around here
Paula have you seen a movie ever have I
ever seen a movie I'm trying to
transition yes have you ever noticed
that there are certain movies where
villains have weapons in them you know
what now that you mention it yes
villains normally do have weapons in
movies and now we're gonna watch a video
from WatchMojo top 10 terrifying movie
villain weapon you see one of our top of
work tears at patreon is whatever video
you request whether it be a reaction or
review or podcast is important we must
do and put up on YouTube and today comes
from our good buddy a actual friend
Andrew Hayes hello go check out his
youtube channel he's been on this
channel before he's one of our top
pledge patrons that's the kind of friend
you need Lord knows that Amy I have
Paris Hilton and Nicole Richie right
here
but the good guys have lightsabers -
Tiffany is ready boys good point yes
every day so be sure to subscribe to our
Channel and read about to get notified
about our latest videos thank you for
this there are some cool that good call
good call it's a scary scene trouble and
they looked awesome while doing it
they're strong enough to tear apart a
train bank vault or a mutated teenage
hero it's too bad they also attach to
the host yeah you know what it is pretty
cool
number nine can do ad
I have one of those the shoulder tendon
can blast a hole straight through these
do those three red dots appear you know
you're in trouble
yeah really was awesome pop culture icon
not only does it look pretty cool but it
doubles as a deadly spy killing weapon
it's one seriously sharp piece of
headwear I mean I guess not because he
was a villain
[Laughter]
with its invention this film certainly
helped solidify it in the mainstream
consciousness Jack starts off as a
relatively normal husband and father but
ends up a crazed man on a mission to
chop up his own family Robin we're not
exactly sure how we got there but Jack
ends up using the axe to bust through a
door and scare his poor wife in a rather
famous scene in this one moment he
claimed it as his own
[Music]
[Applause]
number four oh oh oh what the heck quite
like the bolt pistol when we saw shagird
walk out of the car carrying some kind
of big canister our thoughts mirrored
that of a soon-to-be victim what in the
world is real of course we think the
mystery of the weapon is also what makes
it so interesting the captive bolt
pistol traditionally used to study for
slaughtering them
[Music]
and there was like hardly knee kick on
it that's a smart weapons thinking about
getting a weapon for decades he's been
using it to carve up horny teenagers and
camp counselors that's called getting
the most mileage out of what you have
not only is the machete of course yes
half the heavens adjacent maybe she's
just clean you wouldn't want to spread
infection with it not even dark balls
[Music]
because Darth Maul's is bitchin yeah
that's a good point
heroes lightsabers red could you save it
sort of sorry yeah I was wondering about
that when they showed him fried and
Jason a very scary runs as with many
great things this weapon left us with
some wood to have been overkill however
Thanos would have been Wolverine earth
when you're poking people in the face
with this bad boy and that's exactly why
it made our list
it's like Holly you need a shower
[Music]
do you agree with pigs check out these
other great clips from WatchMojo the
infinity war Thanos glove even if you
haven't seen infinity war everyone's
heard about the fan hos glove everyone's
heard about being very garlic well I've
said half the universe of the damn thing
I probably could have replaced one of
the like an axe or a must for creative
points if nothing else yeah different we
were gonna be looking at a lot of things
yeah I mean if they were gonna keep it
to just realistic like the machete or
Freddy's claws or chainsaw that's one
thing but if you're gonna throw them
like doctor octopus's you know yeah
tentacles why not the pharaohs or an
Iron Man to would Mickey whiplash I
thought it would be a lot more superhero
villains or like the thing in guardians
of the galaxy oh yeah yeah arrow but
that is only he becomes a good guy yeah
or actually it's a good point a class
not about it was a classic villain but
one of the horror community is a
character Victor Crowley I think is his
name hatchet the hatchet series in case
you don't know he has a hatchet as a
weapon the hatchet series so there's
that one too
yeah I guess it's kind of like the axe
though from the shining yes thank you oh
my gosh all suddenly all I could think
of was Silence of the Lambs yeah so in
not correct at all teeth I was gonna say
what about Hannibal Lecter's - yeah
exactly that should have been on this
list that [ __ ] about his ability to
manipulate that's a weapon just couldn't
stop physical doesn't mean it's not a
weapon
yeah dad
your mind is that what your mind is
actually the most powerful weapon of
them all but that scene in spider-man 2
the dr. octopus tentacles that is one of
the scariest scenes in any superhero
movie I've ever seen
operating yeah and then starts going
around like they're they're forming life
to this day when I watch that scene it's
a scary ass so I'm actually really glad
I made the list because it is scary but
yours is the perfect weapon for me like
I would wear like because you wouldn't
look at me and think oh she's carrying a
weapon but BAM would've got one bump
into a crowd of people like you're
walking there okay I just likes
accidentally getting a whole bunch of
people it's like walking around with
like a knife and you just like actually
I bump someone you know maybe it needs
me like it needs to be applied with some
force so if it's just some bumping will
just get light scrapes yeah as opposed
to like Farage gashes maybe because I
don't know the mechanics of the Hat is
it the way he's you know like when
people throw cards at watermelons in it
like yeah yeah yeah just right
so is it like that kind of thing or is
it like a shark like a missile weapon
hat I bet we are one Google search away
but as someone who runs a youtube
channel I have no idea how to work
Google know hey if you know what the
deal is with that hat the hooking candy
man that was upsetting though you know
what I was thinking about it wraps back
in on itself so far it would be hard to
actually get a good to use if your
actual hook purposes it's really need
anything I don't know I don't know
that's what I was thinking about so how
we were watching that have you ever seen
someone with a hook hand no I mean
either I don't even think I've had a
blind person before but I have
definitely I'm just thinking about the
things I see in movies see hook hands
and blind people and I've never met a
blind person
and because I've seen people were unlike
oh they're blind but then apparently
they're not but they have like the blind
stick maybe just have really really poor
vision yeah okay you've never seen a
hook hand in real life I don't think it
seems really hard college professor
who's missing a finger yeah that's the
same definitely the same
I got a classic joke my dad used to tell
me nice to tell on this channel a lot
you want here yes I do
how did Captain Hook die cow he wiped
his ass with the wrong hand oh I can't
let him do his but you get it I thank
you for explaining it cuz I wasn't sure
yeah it happens and I said people flies
over there hasn't sure Oh Texas Chainsaw
Massacre that's not even really for me
about the chainsaw that's just about
like a leather Frye himself is really
well and the way he's just like unwieldy
and just like flinging that chainsaw
upsetting well he did define it with
that because it's Halloween time and
then they're the scarers they always
have the chainsaws everybody not
everyone's love everybody's what about
you know would chainsaws or something
just super deep because there's not even
a chain on it it's not a saw but they
come at you you can put your hand on it
I gonna cause you any harm
yeah there's something scary about that
noise coming at you so here you got
defining weapons not one person with the
gun well I guess sort of the gun the
predator shoulder well that also I was
singing um from No Country for Old Men
oh yeah yeah he turns it into a gun of
sorts but you know is there a villain
who's this like no further gun you know
they don't have like their signature
they smell like like Lara Croft is kind
of known for her to double wheel they
were like yes are usually a guy with the
villains with guns have multiple guns
yeah I can't surely there is a villain
known for their gun I can't think of it
ever like Han Solo is known for his gun
he
gun is pretty basic but again that's
like good guys yeah yeah the only good
guys are known for their guns are good
guys everyone should have a good proven
great right now no gosh no we need some
gun laws for sure but ya know this is a
great quite enjoyed it I had a good time
Andrew Hayes thank you so much
Andrew Andrew you would like this guy he
is four foot five yeah he's like yeah I
want to make him shorter every time I
shot him out and he has his own channel
he does reviews he's in wrestling these
guys just wait like professional
wrestling or like Olympics wrestling
prefer there's an Olympics more
professional well WWE yeah sorry for
doing that Technica I knew exactly we
were talking about it I was like yeah
he's in WWE he's just a very very one of
the nicest people you'll ever meet and I
found out very recently he's made it to
the fifth season of my favorite show of
all time can you guess what that show is
90s is defining 90s x-files no no it's a
funny show it's a funny show from the
90s friends yes I've never watched
friends who do you think recently the
pilot is this weird got the basis to go
I know thanks Andrew for being here
Paula it's on Netflix they paid like two
billion dollars to keep it on their
watch it I'm busy watching Doctor Who I
don't have time for all the fan Theory
TV YouTube channel go check it out right
away guys
out we watch you as a name of the show
she's on Instagram Turner subscribe to
reach a Cajun click that notification
bell yeah